in New York City 40 Riverside Drive on
the Upper West Side it's near my old
stomping ground they are putting up a
building that is going to have a
separate entrance for the lower-income
people yeah this is not made up it
sounds made up separate but equal I'm
not sure so basically they're putting up
this building is being built by a
company called Extell and they're gonna
have a certain amount of affordable
housing which sounds great and the
reason they're doing this is if you put
in some affordable housing then they let
you build bigger buildings so that
sounds good to them they want to make
more money but the people that will be
living in the affordable housing will
also not have access to the gym not have
access to the pools yet to there's more
than one pool there etc etc and the
affordable housing tenants make sixty
percent or less of the median income and
we've got some more info on it the city
approved a proposal from XL in New York
City developer to install a separate
door for tenants living in affordable
housing units to enter the building I
can't believe we're not making this up
exhale applied the inclusionary housing
program which allows developers to
construct bigger properties if the
property includes affordable units for
less wealthy tenants as I just said and
it's gonna be 55 units that will be
designated as affordable housing facing
the street and two hundred and nineteen
units will face the river so also if you
get the affordable housing you don't get
the good view this is obviously
completely bonkers but is this one of
those things where sort of well
intentioned plans just go completely
awry like the idea we were gonna have
affordable housing on the Upper West
Side Riverside Drive nice area and then
it just becomes something terrible I
just you know oh I see a store like this
I'm like man it is a bout time right cuz
I'm so how can we if there's there way
for millionaires to insulate themselves
from the penniless I hope so
I really hope so and I hope those people
don't start buying houses and crash our
economy again that's a poor people
buying them anyway it's a doing this is
this is not a bad idea going bad this is
a good idea but then the capitalists got
involved so this is a socialist idea
from the government saying hey if you're
gonna do this
and we're gonna give you this amount of
property and you're gonna be have to
help out people turns out you're gonna
have to actually be living the community
and so they go hey we can find a
loophole and we could actually stick our
thumb in the eye of poor people and
humiliate them which is what you're
supposed to do if you're rich and your
development right I enjoy it right
because in America if you have money
you're obviously a great person no
matter how you made it that's a sign of
your worthy person and if you're poor
it's a moral failing in America that's
how we look at it it's the opposite of
what Jesus said again I'm scum I know
this from personal experience total
godless soulless completely separate
entrance it's literally like a terrible
episode of Downton Abbey when I read
this story I was like what year is this
are you kidding me is this this so
that's the servants quarters and you
come in through the back end i-i-i was
livid initially and then i got to
reading more about it and i was like wow
so they can't use the pools either and i
was like yeah i guess that's better than
oh you can only use that pool because
that would be the colored pool you know
me nor the gay pool you see them saying
yeah
so i guess it's better to just
completely exclude them and treat them
like crap so for not even for a second
would they think you belong here this
may be your address but you don't but
you don't belong but also the fact that
the the actual entrance is on a side
street like they didn't even even make
it like two doors that were kind of near
each other like we have literally like
hide them in office high street but also
I was just in New York City last week I
grew up in New York City like isn't New
York City supposed to be about everybody
and that you know they mean the rich
people get on the subways just like the
poor people do so this seems so against
not anymore they're not now they have
those fans [ __ ] they got the uber they
got not the uber X what's the fancy
goober they got the good Hoover but what
my point is that this is New York it's
like we are this big mix of everything
and this is just an idea that's just
ripping people apart well that that's
the beauty right so though the rich
people who live in this apartment
building they're gonna be bumping in the
poor people all day long except for that
two-minute walk up to their apartment
when they get in the front door I mean
I'm by the way I'm sure there's gonna be
a janitor who works there on a doorman
not gonna be as rich as them so they're
gonna have to bump into poor people a
little bit a little bit but at least
those are like employed clean people you
know and hopefully they'll install a
separate elevator or at least just say
you can't take the elevator at all if
you're one of those poor ones you know
because that's gross should we have any
sympathy for the developer here who in
his mind was probably going I want to I
could just make a small building for
rich people but I'm gonna use this law
again
devil's advocate today man but you know
to me he's going but I'm gonna at least
use this law to make a bigger thing and
at least get these people in here
benefit I'm sure he's able to sell he's
able to sell more units but I'm sure
there are other benefits as well for him
financially so you don't get any
sympathy for poor doors and I'm sorry